hey hi there seems to be no end in sight
to the protests in Hong Kong and no sign
that the government is willing to give
in to any of the protesters demands day
two of a series of strikes got underway
as news emerged of a leaked audio
recording in which the city's chief
executive is heard telling business
leaders that she'd resign if she had a
choice hours later in her weekly media
conference Carrie Lam said it was
unacceptable that the private
conversation had been recorded and she
sought to clarify her comments about
resigning
I have never tendered a resonation to
the central People's Government I have
not even contemplated to discuss a
resonation with the central People's
Government the choice of not resigning
is my own choice the resignation of the
chief executive was one of the key
demands of the protesters when they
began taking to the streets on the first
of July protesters stormed this building
the Legislative Council the seat of
power in Hong Kong with Carrie Lam in
charge those fighting for political
change here say the chief executives
leaked comments prove what they always
knew they say there's no real power
residing in the building they broke into
and that's why they say their fight is
no longer about Carrie Lam resigning
it's about sending a message to China
that the people of Hong Kong want
democracy the Chinese government again
reiterated its support for Hong Kong's
administration but warned it will act if
the situation worsens
giulia the central government will never
allow the chaos in Hong Kong to continue
indefinitely if the situation in Hong
Kong deteriorates further becomes
uncontrollable and the turmoil threatens
the sovereignty and security of the
country the central government will not
sit idly by the controversy over Kerry
lands leaked comments is likely to had
little impact on the crisis with both
sides no closer to finding a resolution
Wayne hey al Jazeera Hong Kong